[Musique]
et l'on retrouve encore monsieur chaban
delmas dans d'autres secteurs de
l'actualité le premier ministre
l'habitude depuis quelques mois
d'évoquer souvent ce problème il s'agit
de l'habitat insalubre
autrement dit des bidonvilles le point
avec christian guy pour les bidonvilles
nous allons doubler l'action qui
s'appuie depuis 1964 sur la loi debré
doublé l'action de telle manière que au
plus tard en 1972 il n'y est plus du
tout de bidonvilles ni d'un agent
parisienne ni en france ce pari le
premier ministre l'a lancé il y a dix
huit mois il en reste 16 pour le tenir
ce sera difficile car entre février 1970
septembre 1971
un tiers seulement de ces bidonvilles
ont disparu certaines opérations comme à
nanterre ont été menées de façon
spectaculaire mais il reste paris toulon
le havre lille et plus près de nous
aubervilliers en se donnant trois ans
monsieur chaban delmas avec un bulldozer
et de la bonne volonté ne suffisent pas
pour supprimer l'insupportable d'abord
coordonnées action à l'échelon financier
le polémiste a quintuplé les crédits
question crédit pas là messieurs les
préfets des moyens juridiques très
sévère il fallait toucher à ce sacré
droit de propriété
problème juridique financier problèmes
administratifs
mais le plus souvent aussi problèmes
sociaux dont il n'est pas rare de voir 8
10 12 enfants dans la dimension de nos
appartements hlm theiler ou cités de
transit n'est pas fait systématiquement
parmi de très nombreux il ya également
le fret fait lorsque vous ai parlé tout
à l'heure dire qu'on a mais le bulldozer
ont détruit les travailleurs migrants
qui est habitué à rejoindre son lieu de
travail un quart d'heure à pied
pour lui le fait d'être logé à plus d'un
quart d'heure à pied par rapport à son
ancien logement est considéré comme une
déportation
avant de détruire les bidonvilles il
fallait donc s'en donner les moyens
c'est aujourd'hui chose faite de
récentes instructions adressées aux
préfets leur permettent de faire agir en
même temps et au même endroit
la police les domaines l'assistance
sociale les hlm et aussi la justice en
un mot les conditions semblent
maintenant réunies pour que soit tenu le
délai fixé par le premier ministre oui
enfin nous en avons l'assurance des
crédits supplémentaires et des
dispositions d'ordre légal permettent
maintenant que peut être sûr que dans
les trois mois celui dont il va enfin
disparaître mais je dois vous dire que
ça solutionne pas tout le problème parce
que cet aspect très voyant va
disparaître mais les travailleurs
immigrés sont maintenant regagne
maintenant les vieux taudis et derrière
les façades
ils vivent dans une misère tout aussi
grave que celle ci ce danger est réel
900 mille personnes vivent déjà dans ces
fameux taudis où les travailleurs
étrangers s'entassent par dizaines sur
quelques mètres carrés pour le seul
profit des marchands de sommeil corps et
ont gagné alors à supprimer ce que l'on
appelle les bidonvilles horizontaux si
la misère continue à grandir
bien à l'abri derrière rémy plus de
bidonvilles constitué en bidonvilles fin
60 doses alors restera continuellement
mais j'espère dans un délai de quelques
années que nous en sortirons tous le
problème des taudis qui est évidemment
le gros problème à partir de 62
de ce point de vue non ce département de
la seine saint denis
[Musique]